we're looking good this afternoon some
leftover clouds discerned on our red
rock station camera they're from
yesterday's windbag of a storm which
also had a few showers around but we've
got humidity elevated because of the
clouds that will be coming down our
temperature will be going up though into
the low 60s today well above normal
though not quite as warm as yesterday
look at that clearing line boy that
looks nice still some moisture up in
Lincoln County moving off into Utah
again don't get complacent because the
Pacific's still getting its act together
and another storm headed our what looks
like an arrow there of clouds and that
should be in by Saturday night
temperatures today mid to 60s on the
east side 62 downtown Las Vegas the
Lake's looking at 59 Centennial Hills 61
and around the region of 61 in Mesquite
also Pahrump 60 the Amargosa Valley and
Rachel a little chilly up north at 46.
62 is our high bit cooler today but our
normal high is 56. so you really can't
complain looking ahead though there's
cost for a complaint a quiet period
Thursday and Friday and really the first
part of Saturday which will be mild but
then the storm blows in and this one
will have more widespread rains and some
winds and could compromise our New
Year's Eve a celebration our